[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman
who's trying to rebuild trust in her
marriage after an emotional affair we
talked to an incredible guy who's still
trying to rebuild being a dad and a
husband after years of alcohol abuse
and i weigh in on simone bile situation
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up everybody this is john
with the dr john delony show
talk about relationships and mental
health stuff
marriages parenting all of it right here
we're so glad that you joined us do you
want to be on the show if you've got
challenges we take real calls from real
people going through real stuff
lots of it and lots of different stuff
you want to be on the show give us a
call at 1-844-693-3291-1844693
or go to johndaloni.com
ask ask fill out the form and we will
get you on the show
so there's a lot going on um with some
houston connections that's where i was
born and raised
sad news man we lost dusty hill the bass
player of zz top
passed away and latest i've heard kelly
you've i don't know why um they just i
haven't heard any reason yeah i haven't
heard of the cause of death
man so as a fellow texan zizzi taught me
and that's the old school so shout out
to dusty hill and his family
and um also
simone biles is a houston native and
man she has been in the news and so we
will talk about i'll give you my
thoughts on simone bile situation
and um
the olympian who stepped out for several
reasons but the main one is mental
health challenges while she was in
competition and that has just turned the
world on its head firestorm all over the
place
oh man but before we get to all that
stuff um this is national
james kelly i feel like there's a month
for everything now and then there's a
week for everything and now we're just
like a day for every like whatever but
this one's a good one this is
national
make a will month
national make a will month how do you
get a month woohoo
i've already decorated it home and
everything it's fantastic
it's just
all
all just darkness hey kids guess what
we're gonna die someday so we're gonna
write it down on paper for you have a
different notary show up every day yes
just
oh man but it is national make a will
month
my friend john king he's one of best
friends on planet earth one night we
were all sitting around just having a
drink hanging out i think we're watching
fights or something and it was john and
todd a couple others and they were
talking about their wills
and i remember sitting there thinking i
don't have a will like why do you need a
will for we're like 28 or something and
they were talking about this and here's
the executor and they were using words i
didn't even understand and
i looked and it's like i don't even have
a will why do you have wills it's stupid
and john king my buddy said something
that i've never forgotten he said the
only reason you should not have a will
is if you hate your wife and children
i remember going that's a bit much then
all the other guys sitting on the table
were like
yeah dude why do you hate your wife and
kids like why
the government does such a bang-up job
of taking care of everyone else they're
going to be your wife and kids are going
to be lucky to have to go to court for
several months just to get their car
note or to get the title on your house
or to keep your guitars or to whatever
whatever whatever to get life insurance
so cool man way to go dude um that's
what a grieving wife and kids need is
that
i was like man so i went and got a will
made and since then i've gotten several
wills as we got a new child and as we've
moved and changed dates and a lot
here's the thing
i've
since you know in crisis work i've sat
with families who
lost loved ones i've done this a number
of times more times than i can count
and i can tell you a few times i've sat
with families and sat with a wife this
has happened a couple of times where her
husband has died
and wife looks at me
with a look in her eyes that i can i
can't describe it to you other than you
just have to know
and she looks at me and says i don't
know what to do next
because there is no will there's no
money she's gonna have to go back to
work on monday
and this is a saturday like there's
nothing like right the the rent is due
next month
the landlord doesn't care right the
banks don't care
and man i tell you what
one of the cornerstones of existential
psychology is this idea that we all know
at the end of the day
that none of us get out of this thing
alive we all know that we're not gonna
make it and that causes us to create
institutions and ideas and all that
one of the ways you can address
existential angst this idea that at some
point you're not here and it could be
tomorrow
it could be 50 years from now
the reality is you don't know
make
a will it's the greatest gift you can
give your parents
your spouse your kids and if you're
sitting there thinking i'm 36 i'm single
i got nothing i mean make a will for
your mom make it well for your dad make
a will for that friend at church that's
gonna have to come clean this up for
that friend at work that you've
someone's got to come get your stuff
it's a gift
make a will i actually um we have a
partnership here with with uh mama bear
wills i went and when i moved from texas
to tennessee i had to adjust my will
because the rules are different in every
state i used it just so i could say
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna push
something that i don't use
i use this will for my family it's
awesome
we've got a free will preparation
checklist right it covers seven most
important things you gotta think about
plus all the stuff most of us forget to
get this checklist it's free text will
to three three seven eight nine w-i-l-l
three three seven eight nine and hey
here's the thing
it takes about 20 minutes to make a will
that's it
and
i've got a partnership with these folks
we'll give you a discount if you go to
put in the promo code deloney20
deloney20
when you go to this site they'll send
you a link to mama bear wills delony 20
you'll get 20 off your wheel and it's
not expensive to begin with it's
relatively cheap but listen
make a will this week
get online text will to 3379 get online
and do this
with a 70-something percent of people in
the country don't have a will when they
die it's unbelievable
get a will it's simple
and it's going to happen to all of us
take care of your family take care of
your stuff take care of your kids
make grieving easier for those who love
you all right that's it that's all i'm
going to say about it national will
month
that's the strangest party we're ever
having here right all right let's go to
the phones and uh let's cheer things up
a little bit maybe i don't know let's go
to kathleen in macon georgia
we're not gonna we're not gonna cheer
things up are we
kathleen you there
hey i'm here all right kathleen what's
up
hey doctor john
how are you
i'm okay how about you
it doesn't sound okay let's get into it
what's up
um
so
um
i was just calling in because um
i was trying to figure out
you seem real nervous are you okay
okay don't be nervous i'm nervous too
and listen you've heard the show i'm not
great at this and so i i'm setting the
bar really low for both of us so you're
good so what's up
so i guess about
hey you're him hauling around just jump
on in you called like we're in it
just pretend me and you're sitting at a
coffee shop what happened
okay so a quick rundown a couple of
months ago or i guess back in march or
whatever um
well it started back in march um
i changed jobs or whatever and um
i had ended up getting involved
emotionally with
a co-worker okay and i
found out about it and um your husband
found out about it
yes okay so when you say you got
involved emotionally with a co-worker
what does that mean
well i didn't realize that at the time
until afterwards so i like started
researching or whatever and um
you're so around the issues tell me
directly what happened
were y'all texting each other that i
love you and i miss you and started
making plans were you sitting each other
like
like nude photos of each other like tell
me what emotional affair looks like
everything but y'all just didn't hook up
in a hotel like what what was going on
we like talked
a lot texted um
he told me things about his
um
relationship his
wife
um i've told him things about my
marriage
and intimate things that shouldn't have
been
like
talked about outside of marriage
um
i don't know he would and we texted like
a lot okay
um it was never anything
i mean it was inappropriate to me
okay and that
um
he was
a
superior to me so i mean he was my boss
okay
so as far as like texting so your
husband finds out about so
backing out you never slept with him
right
no never held hands never kissed him
never
like never okay so
in your head you've called this an
emotional affair but you know you
crossed the lines that you shouldn't
have that's where we're at right
yeah okay and then your husband found
out
and then what happened
so
well right before this happened a couple
weeks before this happened um
we were already kind of like
disconnected or whatever of course yeah
they're kind of talking and this was
already kind of happening before i
changed jobs um
back in march
and my husband kind of came to me one
day i could say where he's like we need
to talk he's like well i gotta know
what's going on
and i kind of brushed off and he told me
about some issues that you know he was
going through and
he's like you know i really want to work
on our marriage and i was like i do too
a lot and um
so
but i didn't tell him about the
relationship or whatever okay
that i had at work
and because i guess i thought i could
end ended on my own that's what i was
thinking in my head okay yeah um
and a couple of weeks after that that's
when he found out
i was deleting text messages
and um but i wasn't i guess it wasn't
deleting fast enough on my watch or
whatever and that's how i found out
about the messages okay
so then so you
cross some lines
in your heart and in your head and
then you lie to your husband about it
and yeah your marriage was already messy
and um he had been vulnerable with you
and said hey i really want to work on
this and you said me too
and
but yeah that would have been the moment
to say hey
i'm
i'm not doing well either
and you didn't you kept that quiet and
then he discovers this on his own and
now what does he want to be done with
this whole thing
yeah because well back in the past like
even before all this happened i had like
an issue
where like i
racked up like a ton of like credit card
debt and i ended up coming claim about
that a couple of years ago
and
anyways we're working on that
and we're getting that all you know
figured out and paying all our debt down
or whatever
and but you have a history in this
relationship of being dishonest with
your husband yeah
so how can i help you
he has this thing about trust
most of us do just fyi
like man my husband's so weird he's got
this thing about trust all of us do
really
so like
do you struggle with taking
responsibility for stuff
well no i take responsibility because
i'm angry at myself that i do this to my
husband
but like
every day like you know he's always
questioning like he's he
still thinks like we we did you know
more he still thinks every day did you
have sex he just i said no we did not we
did not do anything
of course he's going to because you've
got a history of lying to him
and that's why my real question was like
how do i earn trust or whatever with him
and i just even like i'm 100 honest now
like
he knows everything like he knows all
about our finances i
have he looks at my phone all the time
there's i don't ever close out of apps i
don't delete anything i know but you're
you're
you heal from this you heal from this
type of trust you quit your job you said
yeah i quit my job okay
you heal from this type of
um
dishonesty slowly and over time
and
he has to decide
he's gonna have to decide to be
vulnerable and be willing to be lied to
and hurt again
and
it's gonna take a long time
my guess is you also are dishonest about
other things
and that these are two big ones because
you got really busted right
um
but that there's other things too
and there's little this is and that's
and how many drinks did you have i just
had one but i had four
or
did you call that guy no
and and and
back when y'all were dating have you
have you ever cheated on him before
no
no marshall
sweetheart
okay
um
yeah the
your relationship's not doing great
and what have you all gone to see
somebody
no i asked him to but he won't okay
um
you need to go
for you
you pay you need to go for you that's
all you can do you can't force him to do
anything and um
he's been burned again and again and
again then again
and he's probably not a saint in this
deal right he's probably not
um
but he
you have not given him a reason to trust
okay and so what you have to
do is go start working on you number one
get to the bottom of what are you
bringing to this relationship that's
making it dysfunctional it's making it
not
healthy and that's beyond
getting involved emotionally with a
co-worker okay that stuff happens you
get great friendships that turn into
great relationships that turn into is
your wife like this is your husband like
this and suddenly you're like whoa what
happened what happened and um
so that happens
and then there's a line right and then
there's a sneaking around and then
there's the secrets then there's the it
just kind of gets out of control right i
don't i'm not pissed off at you for that
it happens
i'm i'm not pissed off at you for
anything actually um
but those things happen it's when you
got to flip the lights on and say well
where are we
right and then you've got a pattern of
this stuff that says that there's some
cracks in the foundation of your
relationship do you want to stay married
to this guy
yes
beyond
beyond just wanting to stay married do
you want to have a good relationship
yes
what does that even look like for you
a lot of honesty
talking all the time communicating
beyond that bigger than that what does
it even mean
i don't think you have a good picture of
what that means
and what a counselor is going to help
you do is decide these magic words what
do you want
yeah and i don't think you can answer
that question
fully i think you can answer what you
don't want which is you don't want to be
single you don't want the guy to leave
you
you now realize oh crap this hall can go
away
right i think you know what you don't
want but i don't think you know what you
actually want probably professionally do
you have kids
yeah how many
two two how old are they
um one's not at least six and the other
one is three yeah you're right in the
middle of this
um is a hard season for couples every
couple i know has hard seasons with
little kids like this
um
but i don't it just becomes a mess
especially for a professional woman
who's trying to be a mom trying to be
all this is a mess and i think you got
to go sit somebody i'd be great if he
came with you but if he won't he won't
right he won't he won't you got to go
deal with you
and so i want you to call somebody today
i've got a if you don't have a counselor
in your area which you do
um you can call betterhelp.com they'll
give you a discount you can join on that
i got a partnership with them you have
no excuses you can do it online i'd
rather you go in person right now
because this thing's a mess
and let him know i screwed up and
you can continue to look at anything
i've got i'm going to go take care of
myself
i haven't been who i want to be in this
thing
life is nuts with two little kids life
is like i had to quit my job all this
stuff i just need to get things
straightened down i'd love for you to
come with me and
you cannot talk your way into him
trusting you again that's gone
you've got a show
and not performative not look look look
look but i love you i'm gonna keep
showing up i'm gonna keep showing up i'm
gonna keep showing up and i'm gonna
start working on me
so thanks for that call kathleen that's
hard man it's hard
it's hard i'd love to talk to him have
him give me a call i'd love to hear his
side of this thing too and love love
love to chat with him
sorry there's not like a silver lining
on this one right now um this is just
mess um actually you know what there is
a silver lining on it it's gonna take a
lot of work a lot of intentional work
and a lot of kathleen going first right
um
stuck sorry everybody um uh let's take a
break let's take a break we'll be right
back on the dr john delaney show
[Music]
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you it's why i
wrote this small direct and personal
book called redefining anxiety in this
book i discussed what anxiety is what
it's not and how you can get back on the
road of being whole and well listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndaloni.com and get
your copy of redefining anxiety today
all right let's go to andrew in
charlotte hey andrew what's up man
dr john how are you doing man i'm all
right brother how are you
oh it's a good day because i'm talking
to dr john deloney it's a better day
because i'm talking to andrew man so
what's up how can i help
so here's the thing i'm a recovering
alcoholic okay and i i'm having some
struggles and
i kind of the best way i guess i can put
it is i kind of feel like brooksy from
shawshank redemption you know what i'm
talking about like yeah struggling with
life on the outside yeah um and you know
this life after sobriety and
um how long have you been particular
uh about 22 months 22 months are you are
you in a program of any kind
yeah i joined a.a still going to
meetings okay yep is that is that
working for you
you know it has been um
i got to be honest though lately if um i
don't know if it's you know the group
i'm in the area that i'm in i've become
a little disenfranchised
and yeah i know a lot of that's on me
but it just kind of feels like i'm not
it just feels like for the last
maybe year i've been kind of you know
talking around in circles and
talking to the same people telling the
same stories
and i i kind of feel that i've hit a rut
and like i'm stuck and not moving
forward what are you doing differently
um
i started being a little more relational
with people kind of
outside of the program and trying to get
in touch with
uh
what it means to be a friend and and to
use the people around me that care about
me so something i've been doing
different lately is you know more
one-on-one
chats with people that i trust okay um
which um you know that that's been a
good that's been a good change
so you're um you're married right
yeah yeah kids
yeah we got two kids how's that going
um man it's been so great to reconnect
with my boys um they're two and four
awesome and yeah and that that's been
that's been really good but you know
what i'm struggling with is you know i
i i drank heavily for a long time i i
started young
um i was a i was a professional musician
and very much lived kind of
stereotypical lifestyle yeah and about
18 years of drinking from the age of
like 17 to 35
and
i kind of feel like i woke up
from an 18-year coma
and i've been dropped into the middle of
this battle zone
naked with no gun
and i kind of realized dude i don't know
how to be a husband how to be a father
it's how to be a man
and and i i feel kind of stuck in this
and it's it's been
it's been kind of frustrating and and
where i struggle with most
because my issues are bound but where i
struggle with most is i'm trying to make
things right with my wife because nobody
suffered
more than her
and
it's been so hard you know the this this
recovery process just hasn't been
i i haven't made the progress that i
need to make
um you know
what do you think what do you think
progress is
it's
it's complete openness okay um honesty
and humility are you still lying to her
no
you still lying to your boys i'm not
lying to my boys who are you lying to
i'm doing a lot of lying to
i i guess to
i guess to me
but what about
i i i don't
i listen to these voices in my head to
tell me that
i am not
i'm never going to make this right that
you know this things are never going to
change and you know what dude you just
need to bail
and i'm fighting with that voice yeah
that voice is real man
yeah and that voice has earned its seat
at your table
and at some point
that you'll you'll look over one day and
see that that voice just mouthing but
you won't hear the words anymore but
right now it's loud right
what do you think
paint me a picture brother of what
quote-unquote making things right looks
like
how do you get back 18 years with the
woman you love
like what is that what do you think that
even looks like
when
when we can reach a point where she sees
me
as her leader
as her provider um
because right now i just i don't think
she feels safe she doesn't feel secure
she doesn't feel what makes you think
that
uh well apart from her saying as much
i see it in her frustration um you know
even when she doesn't say it yeah
um
how long have you all been together
uh
uh seven years okay
yeah you've been drinking for 18 years
but y'all been together for seven years
yeah um
does this woman love you
she must man because
no no no no no no no no that was
bullcrap answer does she love you
she does love me yeah she does
yeah so two things i see here
number one
everyone in the world can forgive andrew
but if andrew doesn't forgive andrew
this whole thing ends in a dumpster fire
and until andrew forgives andrew
you go around in trying to perform for
people
right it's like you went like you're a
musician right what what'd you play
was a guitar player okay yeah you're a
guitarist and one night you botched the
solo
you are so hellbent on making sure we
play that sold to the next night so i
can redo it right and you can't wait to
go back to that town because you're
going to let them have it the next time
right you're going to really
relationships don't work like that man
and you're running around trying to
perform for people which you feel like
is connection because you're seeing
people for the first time but people who
are being performed for
you're not connecting with him at all
so last night i uh a buddy of mine
um called
and he said he was heartbroken he said
hey i my wife just had a birthday party
and she told me i just wanted to be
chill and want to go to dinner but i
wasn't going to do that
i threw a massive thing i threw a i
planned everything i started with
breakfast in the morning i made it a big
old deal and by the time evening rolled
around they were in a big fight
and he called me and was like can you
like what did i do man like i did this
and this and this and this and this
and she said i wasn't listening to her i
couldn't see her i couldn't hear
and i i was quiet i was like brother
you threw a party
for your wife you used your wife as a
tool for you to get accolades for
yourself
and you used your wife
as means by which you could throw
something really great so that you her
and other people around could tell you
how great you were
and so you didn't listen to your wife
who gave you exactly what she wanted
which was i just want a small chill
thing and
you did something that you wanted to do
in order to
make yourself feel better
and he was like oh crap you're exactly
right i just wanted her to have a great
party and i was like
then you should do something something
low-key like she said
and where you are right now is very
similar
my guess is
safety for your wife looks like
you being calm and chill and making
coffee in the morning taking the trash
out
and making the bed and saying good
morning i love you
and can we have a hug
and you taking the boys for walks
and
when you are trying to prove leadership
status or provider status
dude she doesn't need a leader and a
provider she's been that she needs a
co-pilot
she needs somebody with her not over her
does that make sense
yeah totally man and the language is
important here
because if you walk up to her and be
like i just want to be your leader she's
going to look at you and go bro i've
been leading this thing for seven years
now i'm good
she probably just wants you to love her
and you can't do that until you forgive
andrew
why don't you love andrew enough to
forgive andrew
oh man
you know it feels it
i really hate the things that i've done
and i guess i keep
dwelling on that i can dwell on stuff
with the best of them that's right
that's right hey you just said it
perfect though
you have a pin in your hand
uh i've got a keyboard okay
i want you to type
a period on that keyboard just type it
one dot
done
you said the things i've done period
past tense over
there are zero things you can do about
those things
none
you cannot edit those sentences they're
done
the only thing you can do is write new
ones or you can just keep reading the
old ones over and over and over and over
and especially for people working
through sobriety but for all of us
ruminating thoughts just letting those
suckers spin feels so good man it feels
like we're doing
heavy lifting
it's it's not man it's a complete burn
of
social and spiritual energy
and what i'm telling you do is quit
reading the old sentences you can change
zero of those things none
what you can change is how much you love
those boys you can make meaning of the
last 20 years
and have these one-on-one conversations
with people who are one two five ten
years ahead of you on this journey
who really know how to love their wives
really know how to be great dads and
they can teach you and you can call them
and you can text them on the mornings
you wake up and say dude my
four-year-old and two-year-old if i hear
one more thing about bluey or
if i have to change one more diaper or
if my kid pees all over the bathroom one
more time i'm gonna set the house on
fire and they'll send you some funny
emoji back or whatever you got to have
those guys in your life but they're
gonna walk alongside and provide a
picture for what marriage looks like
that you don't have provide picture for
parent or that you don't have
man that's where you're at
you cannot change the done things period
and so after this call i want you to
the one challenge i have with aa i love
that it connects people together i love
it with all my heart i love that it
gives structure to people i love that it
pushes people outside of the things
that they can see with their hands the
scientific part and says man you gotta
surrender to something bigger than you i
love all that stuff i love the talking
and talking and talking the honesty and
the vulnerability i love it the one
thing i don't love about it is the
identity that i am and will always be
this
that's my one but beef with it because i
think you can change
and it starts with forgiveness of
yourself and it starts with reconnecting
has your wife told you what she needs
from you
yeah she has what has she said
well the basic thing was
stop lying start communicating
that was the headline and communication
and letting her in yeah that's what she
needs so here's what we're gonna do
starting today you ready
yeah i'm ready
i want you to do three things together
number one
every day i want you to start and end
every day with skin on skin contact
usually by holding her hands and looking
her in the eye and this is gonna sound
cheesy tell her some idiot on the radio
told you to do this okay
and i just want you to stare at her into
her eyeballs for 10 to 30 seconds while
holding her hands that's it say nothing
now brother you're communicating
you're not transferring info you're not
giving her a bunch of facts a bunch of
data you're communicating
okay this is connection
all right the second thing is i want you
to ask her what does your picture for
today look like just today
and not hey what are you gonna do today
well i'm gonna i'm gonna do this
what's your picture today look like
what does
peace and laughter and forgiveness and
joy and what does that look like today
and let her speak into your life and
then you answer with awesome
i'll do what i can to help make that
happen period conversation over
okay the third thing is i want you all
to begin to do a gratitude journal in
the morning and evening together
and so what you're asking for her of her
is five minutes a day
and the gratitude journal is going to be
a single journal y'all keep on your bed
that's just going to be something you'll
do together which is i'm grateful for
five in the morning five in the evening
before you go to sleep
okay okay
that's it
that's it
and when she tells you something no
rebuttals no but yeah but this
no none of that if it sets off your body
and you can feel it in your chest and
you can feel it like oh i'm starting to
feel the shame i'm starting to feel the
crazy you take that stuff to your
sponsor you take that stuff to these
one-on-one conversations you're having
with people
but right now you're learning you're
teaching your wife that you are a safe
place you're not going to lie you're not
going to give rebuttals you're not going
to be like well you should be doing it
none of that stuff
you're safe and what's going to happen
in short order i'm talking like 30 60 90
days her alarm systems are gonna go all
are gonna start tuning way down
she's gonna when she when you're around
and you're looking her in the eye
her heart rate's not gonna take off on
her
her brain is not gonna start spinning
and when hers stops doing that then
yours stops doing that because we're
co-regulated and our heartbeats match
the person in front of us when we're
stressed
and you're gonna see a general
temperature gumming that coming down in
your home
and every single day by the way you're
going to hold your little boys and
you're going to hold your their their
face in your hands and you're going to
look them in the eye and you're going to
make silly faces but you're going to
touch them on the face and when they say
say nope this happens every day you can
tell me you love them
and every time something comes up from
your past that you remember
you're going to say the words out loud
nope
not going there
because you can't do anything about it
oh my gosh that one time i said i was
gonna come home and i didn't show up and
i ended up on a bus but nope
that's it i'm out so i'm stopping it
right
this is you slowly retaking control of
two important things your thoughts and
your actions and by the way dude you got
to have a workout program you got to you
got to you got to start exercising you
got to start eating right these are the
baseline stuff right
andrew 100 you can get there so here's
what i need you to do after 30 days of
this skin-to-skin contact twice a day
gratitude journal today twice a day
asking your wife what does today look
like for you
30 days i want you to holler back at me
and if you say like this thing sucks we
did this this is you're an idiot deloney
i will announce this on this radio show
million people listen
i almost guarantee it's not going to
okay guarantee it's not going to thank
you so so much for your bravery brother
i have a hundred percent confidence in
you and if it makes you feel better um
you're right where you need to be you're
right where you need to be it's gonna be
hard two years in hang in there hang in
there hang in there brother andrew thank
you so so much for that call
all right james kelly
simone biles real quick what have you
all been hearing
it's been very um
divisive i mean you know you're hearing
that she's
um
doing great for taking care of herself
and thinking of her team but then
there's been this side that's been she's
selfish and
she's letting her teammates down and
she's just thinking about herself
it just seems it's just everybody has an
opinion on it and it's pretty strong
opinions too for
something that doesn't affect them
so
here's just my randy i'd love to hear
y'all pop in
you've got the
greatest gymnast of all time
and if you go back and look at some of
her stuff like she's won gold medals
with broken bones in her feet she's
all kinds of injuries where she keeps
going
to do the things that she does
behind closed doors is
hours and hours hundreds of hours
hundreds of falls from heights onto mats
and eating it and bashing your head and
your arms and your elbows on poles and
beams and whatever
so number one we're gonna take off the
table this she's weak
well that's off the table that's absurd
at a level that's so stupid
so if anybody listening and said she's
just weak you're wrong you're an
absolute [ __ ] you're wrong okay so
that's off table number
two
to do a flip off a high dive into a pool
scares me it's not easy right
to do 88 flips in the air whatever crap
she's doing and spinning and doing
circles and twisters and whatever in the
air and then by the way
if if her foot hits the ground and it
moves one inch we're all like oh
she tanked at me
by the way
as it
i think i saw the other day she's the
sole surviving
person who's still on the team who's
involved in all of that
those years of sexual assault from that
evil nasser idiot
so you're you're carrying the face of
sexual assault survivors to the globe
you're the number one on planet earth
and you've gone through all of these
these practices where your mental
toughness is every second of every
practice
and then by the way she's known in the
city of houston for showing up in the
middle of the night during hurricanes
and food drives not as a celebrity but
hey i've got ti
i can throw boxes
so she's known as the person who helps
her community out you've got these other
countries talking about race stuff i
mean
to say she's quote unquote mentally weak
is
idiot
insane off the table you can't have that
there either right
so now i'm left with the
one of the greatest athletes of in my
lifetime the greatest gymnast of all
time
who says
hey last night i was flipping and flying
around the air and i can't do it like i
know myself i know my body i know my
brain i've got a step back
i don't know how anybody eating cheetos
sitting on their couch
i don't know how anybody like with
domino's pizza delivery knocking on the
front door
can sit there and go oh my gosh she
hates america she's a coward what a wimp
she signed up for
dude
i it's maddening
it's maddening
when somebody of her caliber character
somebody for character of mental
fortitude somebody for a caliber of of
professional athlete
somebody of her character who suffered
the trauma she suffered somebody who's
carrying earth
the face of the us olympics
stands up and says i can't i i gotta
step out
and by the way turns it over to somebody
who didn't make the team and then what
that this charger wins a gold medal
what a great turn of events
by the way our team is so good i can
step out and the person who replaced her
who hadn't made the team wins gold right
so here's the thing number one
i
i i don't know i'll never know simone
biles like we're not gonna go hang out i
don't know her i don't know her mental
health i can't speak to that
what i can speak to is just the facts
that to call her
a wimp to call her weak to call her
mentally whatever
is absolute insanity
absolute insanity if you
played high school sports that doesn't
that you don't get to speak into olympic
athlete if you
were like a cool tight end on your
football team you don't know what it's
like to carry
sexual assault
race the face of u.s olympics
internationally during a pandemic you
don't get to speak on that stuff and so
when somebody of that caliber or any
caliber says hey here's what i'm going
through right now what if we all just
said
oh okay and you trusted the person
talking to you what if we just did that
it takes all of our angst out of our
souls it doesn't it it keeps us from
poisoning ourselves hoping simone biles
is gonna feel it
absolute
madness
madness
in it you know what we talk about simone
biles james and kelly but it's also
somebody calls in sick at work
and we're at our house or we're at the
office and we're tired and we're
frustrated and we instantly go they're
not sick
or if they had just done this and they
would they eat like that of course
what if we just went oh man i hope he
gets feeling better
or when we're driving down the road and
a guy cuts us off and we're like that
guy he just
what if we just said man i hope he's
doing okay
if you had a comment a negative comment
about some anything other than i hope
she's okay
man
check yourself man look in the mirror
you don't have no idea
and we've got a culture that just thinks
we can comment on everything
especially negatively
just stop i don't know that's my thought
that's my thoughts i know the least
about it than probably anybody in this
room but the thing first of all like you
never know there's always more behind
the scenes going on than you know yeah
we'll never know about
and unless you're in that position you
don't know what you would do you may
have caved under the pressure a long
time ago you know like nobody knows
unless they're in that position but yeah
the
everybody needing to comment on
everything happening all the time is
just so stupid and exhausting
i just don't understand it like what
and then to see that person say i can't
do this but i'm gonna go out and suck it
up and in the humiliation embarrassment
and i'm gonna cheer my team on
come on man you know i i just looking at
something of a caliber of character that
we just don't see very often and to turn
that into
what a wimp or what a week or she's
gonna regret this whatever
probably not
and if you look at the number of
previous athletes that have come out and
said man i wish i would have had the
courage to do what she was doing because
i was starting to you know michael
phelps has been big out there saying man
i almost had a breakdown i almost lost
it yeah and they're applauding her for
the courage that she had and wishing
they had done that right and you know we
don't have a clue what the kind of
pressure they're under
i i can't even wrap my head around it
right i can't wrap my head around it but
i can know this
one of the ways people ask me all the
time dude you always just look like
you're just chill like you just walk
through life pretty light
it's cause i just choose to believe
people and when they tell me they're
struggling i choose to go man i'm sorry
and i'm also a guy that says tell tells
myself a lot dillon you gotta suck it up
i know you don't feel good i know you
don't feel great or whatever you gotta
get your workout done
like i'm all about that i love jocko too
you gotta suck it up and you gotta do it
and then there comes a moment when
somebody is doing somersaults in the air
and they say if i do this wrong i'm
gonna land on my neck i'm gonna break my
neck i'm not in the right head space i
gotta step out
and then you go sweet who's next
and then in this case who's next won a
gold medal
so rad dude
so rad
so that's my thought on simone biles
it's my it's just my thought on life man
everybody stop commenting on everything
trying to find something negative
let's celebrate people let's support
people
and yeah dude if it's you look in your
mirror suck it up work hard work hard
suck it up and work real hard
and if you can't you can't
and then have the courage to say
i need to step back for a minute
and you step back for a minute and if
she does regret this 40 years from now
it's her regret to have not yours
because america got their gold medal
that you needed so bad all right as we
wrap it up man shout out to dusty hill
today
i went through a lot of zz top songs
trying to find one that somebody
listening to zz top in the car with
their kids wouldn't have to
end the show right now
man the kings of the devil entendre
those guys but
man
every girl's crazy
about a sharp dressed man is that fair
kelly
no
oh yeah definitely all right
it's off the i don't even know what
record this is off of but it goes like
this
clean shirt new shoes and i don't know
where i'm going to
silk suit black tie james do you have a
silk suit
probably not
and i don't need a reason why they come
running just as fast as they can because
every girl's crazy
about a sharp dressed man gold watch
diamond ring i ain't missing not a
single thing then cufflink stick pin
when i step out i'm gonna do you in
because they come running just as fast
as they can
old dusty hill every girl's crazy about
a sharp dressed man right here on the dr
john dolone show